le syndicat de l'e-mail refuse
l'arbitrage proposée par le ministre
jean boulet ministre du travail qui
était avec nous bonsoir monsieur
monsieur le ministre françois fillon
alors quelle est votre réaction à la
décision du syndicat de refuser la
proposition d'arbitrage
main d'abord j'étais profondément déçu
parce que j'ai rencontré les partis ce
matin la rencontre de la dernière chance
assez rapidement même s'il y avait de la
résistance la compagnie a accepté que je
nomme un art b et le c est dit qu après
analyse
refuse à je vais donner un ultimatum à
17h et le séducteur refusez donc on va
penser à la prochaine étape mais c'est
quoi notre avis la prochaine étape je
vais demander à mon le médiateur spécial
que j'ai nommé la semaine dernière suite
à l'assemblée générale et en rejeter à
57 pour cent l'entente de principe de
faire un blitz de médiation parce que la
compagnie vous le savez annoncions et
licenciements massifs à compter de lundi
prochain en fermant le quart de soir à
défaut d'une entente d'ici dimanche pour
le médiateur spécial qui a good
expertise en matière de relations de
travail va faire un blitz de médiation
les parties vont y participer et on a
jusqu'à dimanche je pense le à série
d'événements de cette semaine vont
contribuer à ce que ça soit réglé nous
blitz de médiation commence quand demain
matin oui absolument demain matin il
faut ça se termine quand your une
entente de principe à la satisfaction
tant de la compagnie que syndicat quel
est votre niveau
d'optimisme quant à la possibilité que
ce blitz de médiation mène à une entente
dans les prochaines heures pour son
joueur
ben vont poser la question est ce qu'il
y ait au moins je suis constamment
conscient et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je veux
facilité aider les parties leur donner
tous les outils et maintenir la
communication entre elles parce qu'il
n'ya pas d'entente quand il ya un bris
de dialogue est parti donc le blitz de
la médiation va nous permettre je pense
de forcer les parties à se rapprocher au
taquet et franchit l'une de l'autre
avant d'aller en assemblée générale la
semaine dernière si ça ne fonctionne pas
ces 500 emplois perdus
absolument il ya des répercussions sur
les familles des travailleurs il ya 500
licenciements donc ça c'est des
terminaisons définitive d'emploi sans
penser à la poursuite potentiel du
conflit de travail
l'impact sur les éleveurs de par le
gaspillage alimentaire qui s'en vient
si aucun économique une conséquence
qu'on peut pas accepter ni dans la
région de la beauce est ce que vous
considérez que vous avez épuisé toutes
vos solutions tous vos outils dans ce
dossier là oui absolument et l'arbitrage
était une main tendue j'anticipais que
les deux parties puissent pour régler
rapidement et des douanes est repensé
accepté que je nomme un arbitre de
différent qui aurait entendu les parties
qui aurait rendu une sentence tenant
lieu de convention collective lost un
blitz de médiation et après ça les
outils les aurons tous utiliser donc
c'est encore tôt et la marge de
manoeuvre est extrêmement limitée est-ce
que vous avez agi trop tard est-ce que
l'arbitrage aurait pu venir bien avant
non absolument au génome et deux
conciliateurs rapidement après le début
de la grève les deux conciliateurs ont
été tellement actif que ils ont quand
même subi une proposition appelons-nous
match et c'est lyon qui a fait l'objet
d'une entente de principe donc la
compagnie était d'accord pour l'exécuter
syndicales étaient d'accord d'accord et
mardi dernier en assemblée générale
contre toute attente
57% un des salariés en assemblée
générale réunie en rejeter sur d'autres
et donc ok on est prêt et le médiateur
spécial il continue ses enfants mais
parties sont éloignées mais poli ramener
l'or où elle gérait à 20 l'entente de
principe
merci beaucoup monsieur boulet merci à
monsieur fillion à bientôt pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne i cirdi